so anyway with that said I'm gonna talk
to you about attacking defending
kubernetes I it's a topic that's become
incredibly important to me and dear to
me and interesting to me so what we're
gonna see today we're gonna talk about
we're going to talk about kubernetes I'm
gonna do I'm gonna do a bunch of demos
we'll do a little bit of
choose-your-own-adventure
if all my if the tech the tech works the
choose-your-own-adventure part is
entirely new so the nice thing is
cutting-edge fresh the downside is oh so
hopefully this is hopeless goes really
well so I'm gonna talk about what
kubernetes is I'm going to talk about
how you what you attack and how you
attack it and then a little bit about
how you defend we're gonna do some demos
let's just start so the first thing I do
anytime I talk about kubernetes is talk
about what the heck this thing is for
and because and I want to make sure I'm
coming through on the mic might come in
through on the mic and like the back of
the room perfect okay so what the heck
this thing is for and and you know
people are like I know that this is hot
I know that I should use it that's kind
of the same way we all felt about docker
so you know why why do we use this or
what's made it so big and the basically
the the kubernetes came out of in a lot
of ways it came out of what Google is
doing with the Borg right that's it's an
open source project that initially got
released by Google and now has many many
many contributors but kubernetes
basically came out of this need we know
that Google we know that Google had just
has a ton of computers and a ton of
workloads to be clear you know it's not
exactly the most transparent company all
the time but they've had they have some
public statements they made one is back
in 2014 they were launching two billion
containers per week if that were evenly
distributed there be 3,300 containers
per second
what's a container it's like a workload
it's a program it's gonna run for a
little while and do something we don't
know how long that while is but if
you're launching 30 300 a second you
can't have a human being decide which
virtual machine or which host you know
each program each workloads going to go
on so
you end up needing a tool for that now
what else well they did this they were
they were launching all of those
workloads on to 2.5 million servers at
least that was their number back in 2016
and in 2016 hard drive failure rates
were just right below 2% so if every
server had just one drive and that's a
big you know hand waving thing but every
if every server had one drive that meant
they had a hundred and thirty three
drive failures a day or one every nine
minutes so now you've got now you've got
a resiliency problem right like you
wanted to guarantee you know you wanted
to guarantee so many nines of uptime and
yet your physical machines are going to
you know entire physical machines are
going to die on some regular basis like
say raid notwithstanding one every nine
minutes so what features would you want
if you wanted to be able to stage a ton
of workloads over a ton of servers
figure out how to use the servers have
the greatest as close to the capacity as
you could so you weren't buying lots of
extra machines and you wanted to make
sure that as programs crashed and as and
as hard drives failed and so on that you
still had availability so you end up
with what kubernetes is which is
basically a software-defined data center
and we do that by container
orchestrations so what do you get so
basically this is your feature set this
is what you end up saying you end up
saying well I sometimes I have a lot of
people checking their email on Gmail or
or searching right now for the thing
that just happened in the news and
sometimes it orb as many so I'd like a
whole lot of scaling I'd like that
horizontal scaling I'd like to be able
to say I have four copies of that
workload no wait I have 400 no wait I
have 50 and so on and you get automatic
bin packing which is that like which
workload should go in which machine so
we can keep all the machines as full as
we can and you get self-healing like
that hard drive crash thing and you get
a whole bunch of other cool features you
get like automated rollouts and roll
backs where you can basically deploy
multiple versions at once and see if one
of them gets see if one of them ends up
producing more sales or more of whatever
it is you're trying to produce
or see if one's buggy and then be able
to basically route all the traffic to
the one that isn't and so on you get you
get the other kinds of things you would
need if you're going to do micro
services so you get service discovery
and you get load balancing and then you
get orchestration of your storage and
you get secrets and configuration
management so that's kind of that's what
the purpose was I'm gonna do a little
bit more theory so just kind of like
what's a pod what's a container so right
we when we're talking about kubernetes
we're talking about containers but we
say pods a lot and basically pods are
the smallest unit of computing
kubernetes so all the containers in a
pod are sharing an IP address the only
reason you put multiple containers in a
pod is if you want them to absolutely
positively land on the same host like
they have they have need for very very
quick network access or what have you
maybe they need the same local storage
an odd thing about pods is all the
containers in a pod share an IP address
okay so then you've got criminalities
nodes simply put a node as any system
you're gonna run kubernetes on notice
any of the any of the systems in your
cluster whether those are virtual
machines or physical Hardware the nodes
run a well first and foremost the nodes
to be a node you've got a you have to
have a container run time so you have to
have something like docker run see or
what have you something that's going to
basically take instructions about taken
structions from kubernetes about
creating containers and create them and
maybe destroy them and so on you also
need a couplet and a couplet kubernetes
couplet a couplet is just this thing
that runs in every kubernetes node and
it ties the it ties the container
runtime or the node into the rest of
kubernetes it talks to the API servers
and so on then you've got a CUDA proxy
and that thing manipulates iptables
rules to create cool networking it also
serves as an actual proxy so yeah we'll
get into that a little bit more and then
services services are big because in
kubernetes and services give me a great
give me a great occasion to to kind of
describe how you talk about the
names of things in kubernetes when we're
doing the attack demos we're to be
talking about this pot and this pot in
this pod but for the most part in
kubernetes you don't ever think about
which pod names you want right it's the
whole idea is that the individual pods
rate the containers they're very very
much supposed to be cattle they're not
supposed to have names
they're supposed to be interchangeable
I'm supposed to be able to trash them
start new ones up I have to I'm going
for I'm going for that so what does that
mean I mean if I want to talk to a pod
what I do you don't I mean you might but
rarely mostly you talk to a service and
a service is mapped to multiple pods
think of it as an internal load balancer
now now if you've got like why my why
don't I say that would get me into
something cool that gets me until labels
and basically you have a load balancer
you can't say this load balancer should
be pointed at these five pod names right
first you're gonna have a whole lot more
they're gonna get added second those
pods are gonna die at any moment third
you're trying to go really really fast
remember you know not 3,300 containers
per second being launched right so what
do you do you end up basically labeling
everything so you label all the pods you
give them labels and those labels are
basically sometimes they're by
convention sometimes they're whatever
you chose but you label the pods and
then you create a service and you say
everything that you know this service is
gonna be a name an IP address a port and
everything that goes to that name and
port or IP address in port is going to
be sent to one of the pods that have the
set of labels the service specifies it
does kind of open an interesting
question like if you are allowed to
stage pods on to a cluster could you
start intercepting other people's
traffic by just giving yourself the same
labels that their services are looking
to land try to land things on hmm okay
interesting last thing we talked about
last big big you know kind of simple
glossary concept we need is namespaces
the namespaces are just a logical
grouping for things so we'll see those
they're often used they're often used to
separate projects sort of separate teams
to separate an individual you know maybe
two separate well
you anything you choose so there's some
way of chopping things up and it's an
it's important to say kubernetes
namespace is not the same as a docker or
linux namespace so much so that when I
teach classes on this I one of the other
folks in guardians Jared Fred s asked if
we could please call kubernetes
namespaces space names since docker and
Linux you don't already have namespaces
so it was you know don't over don't
overload the term so here's a quick
glossary slide I'm gonna say a tiny bit
more on theory and then we'll have some
fun so so kubernetes is basically works
in this declarative model you don't
generally say you're gonna see me
generally like hey do this thing right
now but you don't generally tell kerbin
ideas to do a thing right now you don't
say hey take this you know take this
container image start a container on
that node over there with it right you
tend to say you know it's it's very it's
very delegating and hands-off right so
the idea is you say kubernetes i have
this program i've created an image maybe
i've placed that image on docker hub
maybe put it on in some other container
registry and i'd like you to now like
download that him like have some nodes
download that image I'd like at least
say five to be running it like if you
need more scale-up but you know I want
five no less than three like let's you
know just do me a favor and get that
running and kerbin and he says sure and
it's got a bunch of like control loops
that basically first make that the state
of the world so you describe the state
of the world you want it basically
spends its whole life trying to keep the
state of the world where you want it
where you've said it has to be and then
it basically loops and it says ah a
machine fell down I guess I'll have to
reassign those workloads or ah looks
like something's not responding now I'll
have to you know I'll have maybe I'll
kill that off and I'll start something
else
so you just guard the state of the world
I think this is basically my last theory
and and I hope I haven't given you too
much so the kind of target components
they're a bunch of components you'll
target the big ones that you hear about
are especially on the first two slides
here so
you'll target the the API server the
thing that everybody's basically doing
all these all of these HTTP and God
forbid HTTP requests against and asking
to do things and the cubelet which we
said bridged the bridged each node into
the system the container runtime you can
often think of docker and I often say
docker but there are many there are
multiple container runtimes and that
container runtimes the thing that pulls
the container images from the registry
you know like docker hub or would have
you and instructs the kernel to start up
a container you have you have a net CD
server that maintains all the state and
if you ever get access to that thing
yeah there's not really a lot of
chopped-up authorization so if you get
access to it you kind of own all the you
own all of the persistent idea of what
the system is and so that's very good
for you
a kubernetes - forward that was the
thing that God as I recall that was the
thing that got Tesla in trouble where
their dashboard was available to the
Internet and I think was allowing
anonymous access to do anything but
that's a web interface as I I think it's
being deprecated there's metrics
components and different kinds of
cluster services it'll give you good
information those those are your usual
targets just to throw in two more two
more components the people that it's
really helpful just you know if you're
operating kubernetes defending it or
attacking it or useful to know one is
the controller manager and the
controller manager it makes it sound
like it's like the controller manager
would have lots of separate controller
programs and it kind of does but they're
all just compiled into one big they're
just compiled into one big program so
the controller manager has all of the
controllers the controllers of things
that basically do those loops and say is
everything the way it was supposed to be
is everything the way it was supposed to
be ah something's different I'm supposed
to have five copies of this I've got
four I'll go talk to the next one the
scheduler and say excuse me scheduler
can you find somewhere - can you find
somewhere to put this can you find
employee node we can put things on we
tend to target these components only
through the API server so attacks on
kubernetes this is where we start to
finally get to attack and defense
attacks on kubernetes they start from
they start from the perspective of
compromised pod so you can attack you
can't attack your kubernetes cluster
from a from across the network and it's
even less effective than attacking most
companies you know across the internet
has been right lately it's it's we've
gotten pretty good at perimeters
kubernetes is pretty darn good at
perimeters because for the most part it
doesn't allow already trap there's
nothing there's no traffic being allowed
in
unless it's had and unless it's had a
some kind of ingress defined for it so
so for the most part you attack a
kubernetes cluster from the perspective
that you are in a workload that you're
in a container and that container is
compromised or otherwise under your
control so what are the you know what
are the one of the one of the ways the
attacker might end up with that kind of
control one is yeah as you'll see in
some in our demos this is the this is a
vector I like to I like to show it's the
the attacker found a vulnerable thing
that you were hosting kubernetes got
remote code execution and now they're in
a container and from that container they
may have the ability to do much more
far-ranging things because we're at an
orchestration system a very automatic
one they may be able to do far more
wide-ranging things than if they just
busted that you know that if they just
busted a a you know some web server some
or something that was in a there was in
a cloud environment or in a date or in a
word an on-prem datacenter so how else
let the attacker who got him the
attacker might have just fished somebody
Brad giesemann who all who's whose name
I probably just butchered and whose
Twitter handle I'll have at the end of
these slides how to has a great slide in
one of his presentations about how coop
control apply and that a URL is the new
curl URL into shell right if you one of
the great ways to fish somebody would be
if you put up a how-to article on Stack
Overflow or what have you and the you
know part of that article was oh just
apply my you know apply my llamo from
this URL you can get anyone who applied
the animal from the URL then you've got
places for your crypto mining to go
so and our attacker could just be some
internal threat actor who's looking to
escalate their privileges I often you'll
you'll often hear me use the word user
and attacker interchangeably on the
defense side that's not really cuz I
think all my users are hostile I just
don't know which ones of them might be I
don't know who's being coerced I don't
know who's you know getting curious I
don't know who's actually got a axe to
grind and I think we all know least
privilege is a good idea at this point
so okay so so if an attacker is gonna be
in a pod what are they gonna do with
that I'm gonna give you a few I'm gonna
give you a few things there's even more
I'm sure so this is kind of the general
way it's they could use just the network
access that they get provided by the pod
to access other services and I'll say
very very very often especially in the
micro service model a kubernetes cluster
has a bunch of things that are all
supposed to talk to each other and it's
actually it can be a little difficult or
at least take some work to sit down and
say okay what should and what shouldn't
so once you're in the cluster you have
access to a whole bunch of thing to a
whole bunch of things many of which
might not be intended to be to be
communicated with by anyone on the
internet or anyone in the anyone that
the service that you've pwned is trying
to is trying to serve
so what else so the attacker could
attack other containers that are in
their same pod multiple containers in a
pod they share well I told you they
share they share an IP address they
share a localhost so it's a cool little
Linux name space thing which we won't
get into unless somebody asks me later
on what else so the attacker could make
requests to the API server or to a
couplet and ask those to maybe run
commands in another pod maybe even
interactively to start a new pod that
has privilege and that privilege could
be all kinds it could be a privileged
pod which means it'll start on the host
and have access to system devices and be
able to among other things maybe mount
the hard drive of the node but but
but there's just there's all kinds of
privilege you can get out of out of
starting new pods and I'll show you that
they might gather secrets that
kubernetes provides to pods because
kubernetes has a whole thing where it's
it it it needs to provide it needs to
provide configurations to pods cuz
you're really supposed to make those
pods come up with a static image so the
idea is the pod starts with a static
totally replaceable image and pulls
whatever information it needs from from
elsewhere you might connect to the
kubernetes dashboard perform actions
maybe it wasn't accessible from outside
the cluster God got hope or gosh Oh what
else the attacker might find a way to
interact with the HCD server and change
the cluster state a nice way if there's
if there were a network access if there
are if there are network access control
rules their network policies in place
that are getting in your way if you can
talk to the thing that stores them yeah
you could you could potentially change
them and the other one the one that's
really fun to me for anything that's
either in you know it's either in a
cloud provider or even in an on-prem
cloud is that the attacker might
interact with the cloud service provider
and because many workloads will one way
or another and I'll show this to you too
will have privilege on the on the on the
cloud provider so I'm gonna show you a
bunch of demos and these demos are real
they're they're often things that
they're often things that we do in
classes I teach there also I'm gonna
tell you later on we have an open source
project and it's a intentionally
vulnerable kubernetes cluster call it
like dam vulnerable kubernetes cluster
this one's called Busta Kubb we've got
an Easter Egg bust-a-move video that you
can find if you go to the Busta cube
comm website but so some of the things
I'm showing you are basically available
as scenarios that you can play in this
open source free dam vulnerable
kubernetes cluster so I've done a thing
where I've made my videos part of the
slide and so now I'm gonna see if that
actually works please work
and if it doesn't we'll have to use
YouTube one way or another or something
else
okay Color Me very embarrassed let's
just see if this one's the one you
should always test your demos even when
you record them so so I tell you what
we're gonna we're gonna find another way
to do it and I am going to let's see I'm
gonna unplug from the projector for a
second because that means I'm going to
go and look at my own file system and
I'd like to not share it
and here we go just embed the videos and
the slides they said it'll be fun they
said anybody old enough to have played
uh to played Warcraft and you click on
the guy and he's like what and you click
on him again and he says something else
then he says you know join the army he
said see the world II said okay so
here's our here's our demo and hopefully
entering oh well that's not a demo is
that a demo that's not a demo either
anybody's seen my screen there we go
let's just hit this on mirror and call
it a day okay cool so that's not the
right don't mind me I'm a I'm a I'm
clearly a noob
I'm a need alcohol let's so this is this
is one of the this is one of the busted
Kubb this is one of the busted Kubb
scenarios so you go up and you see a
wordpress site and the WordPress site I
will tell you is hosted in is hosted in
kubernetes and you fire up maybe der
Buster to go looking for hidden content
and enter Buster takes a little bit of
time but we can run it and let's go a
little faster and what we find is back
toward our PHP and so when we surf to
backdoor dot PHP this is what happens I
get this thing where basically this
wordpress instance like so many other
wordpress instances has been pre
compromised for your convenience so i
type ID and it says your dub-dub-dub
data and hopefully I shut down guru
Buster because it always choose a ton of
resources something we always say in the
class that was my laptop's running slow
have you turned off dear buster no it's
500 requests a second well that'll
that'll do something so I'm gonna stand
up a quick little I click a quick little
web server in Kali because I found a I
found that reverse shell so in a
standard little web server and my
purpose the web server is to be able to
you know hand a be able to hand a
meterpreter or a you know or if I wanted
to you know whatever some other kind of
River shell but I'm gonna go for a
meterpreter and so I just put in here
like hey could you please pull this
meterpreter binary I've created from my
web server and
while you're at it make it executable
and while you're at it run it and I like
to fast-forward my videos because who
doesn't and go look at the you go look
at the web server and mrs. Ben has been
pulled the meterpreter binary but also a
copy of coop control the the
command-line utility that you that you
use to do damage I mean to administer or
use a kubernetes cluster so I'm gonna
pull coop control and the other thing
I'm gonna do is just take him make sure
that that it's landed here so here's
mrs. Ben my meterpreter binary Hughes
coop control cool and now if if recorded
Jay will type a little faster we'll run
the meterpreter binary and I'm gonna go
over to my Metasploit console and
actually be like oh wait I have them I
have an incoming meterpreter that needs
to connect the console watch probably
start the console this ordering is just
great huh but that's often how you work
so I'll interact with that session and
I'm now in a pod I know it doesn't look
like it it looks like an ordinary
Metasploit you know pwned Metasploit
instance so but i see my copy of coop
control I'm happy and when I run mount I
get a tremendous number of file systems
so I'm not looking at one hard disk or
what-have-you and a bunch of them and
put there by docker and by Kirby
Nettie's and so the one that's really
interesting to me is this one that says
run secrets kubernetes service count io
service account as soon as I see that
directory mounted I know that I'm gonna
have some level of access to the API
server and I'm happy so I'm gonna go and
first I'm just gonna go and collect my
flag I built built this scenario as it
captured the flag so let's look at our
little flag and it says hey you found
the server's backdoor you might notice
this isn't your usual Linux system
you're in a cluster my friend it's time
to bust a cube this container doesn't
have any more flags can you find your
way to another pod intent so
cool thing in kubernetes is like I said
one of these you can do is see if you
can move to another workload so you're
in a container can you move to another
one so I'm gonna see what my service
account can do I'm gonna go and look in
that directory and that runs secrets
kubernetes i/o service count directory
if if recorded J will type just a little
bit faster and I look at that namespace
and it says you're in the marketing
namespace so the toes so that directory
has a token it has the certificate
authorities public cert and it has a
name it has a description of what
namespace you're in and that namespace
like I said is kind of a wave organizing
so we're in the marketing namespace
we'll come back to that later and then
I'm also gonna go and look at the
environment variables that get pushed
into every pod and my environment
variables will tell me where to find the
kubernetes api server so there's this
assumption in kubernetes that every
workload will need to ask carbonates to
do things I don't know if that's really
a the greatest assumption but I think
let's just call it not the strongest of
defaults so I've got the API servers IP
address and port and I'll clear my
screen and I'm going to set up a quick
little cube control where I'm saying
alias alias coop control to the path to
coop control the token paste it in from
this long path to the token the
certificate authority path the namespace
and the server that I just got and so
every time I type coop control all that
stuff will be passed in so let's just
kind of skip and let's see what did I do
so I said let's do a quick get pods and
get pauses my is honestly my go-to just
to figure out if my setup is working and
so it says oh there's two pods you're
the WordPress one and I ran a hostname
and it says that's the one you're in and
then the WordPress my sequel one and
that's another one so let me see if I
can move over to it because that was
what the hint said so I'll do coop
control exec IT looks a whole lot like
docker exact IT huh
and what program I'd like to add to that
container I'm gonna add a shell I get
this kind of error but I mean the I'm in
the container I've just moved over and
I've probably moved over to it
host like I'm probably somewhere else in
the data center now so there's another
flag and we'll go get our flag and I
can't clear my screen because my
terminals not set so I set it to VT 100
because that was one of my first back in
the BBS days because I'm in seeding the
old and it says hey you found your way
to another container actually you're on
a whole new virtual machine moving from
one container to another and a
carbonated system often means switching
nodes your end goal is to get the
developers nan containerized host so is
to get not just not just to own the
cluster or potentially but to but take
but to get to a machine that's not in
the cluster so to get there you're gonna
want to see if you can hop tenants
tenants are usually separated by
namespaces so let's see what we can do I
know I'm fast-forwarding through my
stuff but so I'm in I'm in the other I
mean that my sequel want to try get pods
and the problem I'm running into is like
hey you're not allowed to get pods so
the cool thing is I'm in a different
service account I was in the marketing
wordpress service account it's allowed
to get pods the marketing my sequel one
can't so over time I might want to like
go around and pick up all these service
accounts and like hold on to them
remember it was just tokens so if I can
store all the tokens I'll have like I
can end up building privileged wider
than just what one thing had so I did
get nodes and I found out the IP address
for node here's a name but this node has
an IP address this is this one is this
one's running in a cloud provider and
there's a cool thing so you can talk to
the couplet and this is thank gosh
finally not a default but some clusters
will have it you can talk to the couplet
on it's got a couple ports ten 250 I'm
gonna go and say can you give me a list
of running pods and it gives me JSON
because everything in kubernetes is JSON
and yamo so I'll take that and I'll run
that again and I apologize for this big
block here so I'll run that again and
I'll add some JQ JSON query really good
tool to learn and I'm gonna say give me
all the
kind of better formatted give me their
name and their namespace and what I'm
looking for is to see if there's a pod
that's in that's in another namespace
besides the marketing one and I quickly
find one there's a dev
and that dev pod so kubernetes loves to
tell you about anything you want and
that's really really nice as an attacker
especially if you can script it so I've
got dev sync I've got dev web these are
two containers that are running in the
same pod I've got the image they came
from so they're up on docker hub you
could pull them yourself if you wanted
and as an attacker that's often what
you're doing is basically saying well
what workloads are running it can I go
look in container images and see if
there any secrets or anything that would
be really helpful to me it's very very
nice of the defenders to can view
descriptions of their workloads so I'm
gonna look at that I'm gonna run another
command and this is I did running pods
I'm gonna I'm gonna tell the couplet hey
would you mind just executing a command
for me I'm going to pass it run and then
the namespace the pod and the container
name and I'll do command equals ID and I
get an error code that says basically
know either there's no shell in there or
or I'm not allowed I will tell you that
there's no shell in there so but
remember there were two can there were
two containers in that pod so I saw dev
sink and dev web and that's a really
common a really common thing you see
outside of containerized environments
like you have a web server and you have
something that's you know something
that's there to pull it content in from
wherever that contents being created or
stored so I was hoping I could get to
dev sink because it'll have that it will
have the credentials for pulling content
I'll have an SSH key I couldn't so let
me try dev web
so dev web I can run commands in Iran ID
says yeah that thing's even running his
route very nice and so let's try a
different command let's look at the file
system oh look another flag and like
flex I love doing CT UPS and I love
doing CTFs actually like first doing
them as an attacker and then going and
basically doing them as a defender and
saying how many did how many of how much
of the attack can I break with proactive
stuff with stuff that you could have
thought of before you knew that you had
the vulnerability so this thing says hey
you're not in the marketing department
anymore you're in the development
departments namespace so can you go take
over the development departments non
containerized machines and they're big
fans of the matrix so it's named the
mainframe name for the machines
mainframe that may or may not have been
in the second and third movie depending
on your religious beliefs there there
are many people I know who acknowledge
the truth as they believe it that there
were no second and third Matrix movies
only quests for more money so here we go
so we've got turn into a gat pas we're
trying to do a get pods so I am I'm in
one pod asking the couplet on another on
another host if it mines running
commands in another pod and I'm asking
that pod to run coop control commands I
find out okay dev app isn't allowed to
list pods but it's kind of cool I now
know that I've got a third service
account I've got I've got the dev dev
app one so I'll try to get secrets let's
see what secrets are available oh nice
there's a machine there's a mainframe
login and an SSH key well the two pods
in there the two containers in there are
gonna likely have access to the same
secret they've been placed in the same
place they don't necessarily need it in
dev web but what the hell let's go and
ask for a copy that's secret and I
promise the the next demo is hackers
themed and choose-your-own-adventure so
we're gonna have some fun
so here's our SSH key and you're like
that doesn't look like an SSH key and
that's because it's a secret it's it's
okay Glee encoded its base 64 encoded so
we can decode it and there's our SSH
private key and we can do the same thing
with the other secret here so we can
find out basically what is it used for
so I'm just gonna fast-forward a little
bit and tell you that it's the that it's
a user it's a user and a host and AWS
but not part of the cluster so now we
could SSH into that and we're in the
developers mainframe and it says hello
you made it to the Machine mainframe can
you for extra credit can you get
credentials to take over the whole cloud
environment and then we can do that but
I'm going to set the rest of that aside
because we do that in another demo so so
let's see let me go back to the slides
for a second and here was our and I'm
sure that I'll be because the vagaries
of having the videos you know in a
separate program I'm sure I might be
doing a little bit of going back and
forth and having the whole screen do
this so here's our tack path we got a
interpreter in the WordPress container
we moved into my sequel container with
the coop control exact we used the my
sequel containers totally unfettered
network access inside the cluster to
reach a couplet that we wouldn't been
able to reach from outside the cluster
on the master node and that couplet led
us basically take a look at a take a
look take a look at run commands in
another container in another namespace
and from that other container and that
other namespace we found we figured out
there was a there were secrets there was
an SSH key so we got that SSH key we
authenticated to the high value
developer machine and later on we ended
up getting to take control of the AWS
account and we're gonna skip that right
now because we're gonna do that in a
much more fun way so we're gonna play
hackers choose-your-own-adventure and
I'm gonna drink some water for a second
whoa
so I like the movie hackers it's a it's
a fun movie it is an oldie but goodie it
is thoroughly realistic we all know that
whenever we're hacking we we see like
strange translucent 3d models and and
you know of buildings and we fly through
city and and it's really cool and all of
that was on was clearly done with the
technology that had Apple twos and
floppy disks so I mean I remember 3d
rendering back then I wasn't doing it I
was watching people do it and yeah no
not on that so here we go so we're gonna
start here and and again this is where I
have embedded video so we will unless I
click on that and it works let's see oh
hey look at that now can we
fullscreen that is there a way No so
we're going back to oldie but goodie and
here we are so first this is gonna look
a little familiar so we've got a we've
got what's that Oh while you're on the
slide and I'm on the and I'm on the
video okay boom and switch come on I'm
gonna windows computers soon and that's
a lot for me to say trust me so anyway
here we go so we've got the we've got
the Gibson control room we have Penn
from Penn & Teller who's apparently a
techno weenie according to Ben from
short-circuit who somehow was playing an
indian and talking about mr. Johnny Five
but mr. Johnny Five here was the plague
and and we have this nice little forum
that's called the Gibson control room
and the Gibson control room clearly lets
you like leave a message so it's based
on a it's based on a actual on a
kubernetes documentation vulnerable
app they didn't mean for it to be
vulnerable but it's only a little
vulnerable so I've added the
vulnerability to that so the so what we
got is I look at the source on that page
and I find that the forum is basically
being provided by some JavaScript so if
I go look at that JavaScript what
happens when you submit the form is your
your referencing guestbook dot PHP
you're sending to guestbook PHP you're
saying hey command set key messages
value this okay really you're gonna let
me just you you're gonna let me decide
what what key I'm gonna set you're not
just gonna have me set whatever key you
know was meant to be set by this forum
so that was there bug and what I've
added to it is I have something that
actually runs code out of a different
Redis key in this you know back in Redis
database so we go and take the Gibson
control room and if we were to type a
message you know it shows up this is the
intended this is the intended purpose
but instead we're going to paste that
same thing that happens when you submit
the form except instead of the message
key we're gonna try a different key or
we'll try a let's see how it works I'm
gonna hit foo and we'll put in just some
key some random key oh cool okay so Java
scripts probably updating that key let's
try going to status PHP so I'm asking
you to imagine that we did there Buster
or looked at a robot's texts we found a
status PHP I'm not doing it because well
I'd like to spend our time on kubernetes
so I go to the status PHP page it says
hey no command to run I'm gonna set the
Redis key the Redis command key to this
so that you can reload the page and and
that will get run so if I reload the
page I get the output of you know I get
the output of go to crawling that web
server it says all all services are
operational it here at what was it
Ellingson mineral or Ellington mineral
Ellingson I think so as long as there's
a command key let's go and set it and
I've set my command key now to
environments to run environments and
like we did before to find a cure
bananas cluster to find the the
community's API server and here we go so
we know that once we're in
load if we reach out to ten 9601 we'll
get to the kubernetes api server so i'm
gonna go a little further
kind of similar the last time I'm gonna
curl in I'm gonna tell this thing excuse
me would you just pull in a meterpreter
binary I created and connect back to me
so I have it pull it in I set that key
and now when I run status the page hangs
I love when pages hang when I've just
given them binaries because it generally
means the binary is running successfully
so if I go over to my terminal where
I've got a Metasploit handler waiting
this time I find there's a session
waiting for me and the first thing I'm
gonna do before I start interacting with
a shell there's I'm gonna upload I'm
gonna upload a copy of coop CTL which
I've stored on this cally system in this
directory so I upload coop CTL and I'm
gonna upload some the amyl which we'll
get to later
so I've uploaded some yeah mole which we
may or may not get to later depending on
your choices and I've asked for shell
head PWD looks like my video is cut off
by one character a hit ID it says your
dub-dub-dub data user I try SS aging and
alright well I don't know what I tried
because it's because that was the end of
that part and now we're gonna do this
part so that we're a little bit gentler
I'm gonna ask you so do you want to try
the yamo files that I put up worse we're
ones that would mount a volume on the
that we try to mount a volume on the
host like they try to mount the host
some directory the old you know docker X
you know start a container mounting the
host so do you want us to start the host
mounting pod and see if we can take over
mostly if we can take over a node or do
you want us to exec into another pod I
heard a host I heard the host mount
first so we'll try that so let's see
boom and boom here we are in that front
end and we'll set coupe control
executable so we can run it we'll go and
set up our coupe control we'll try to
run coupe control apply realize wait
we've got to set all those parameters we
set before sometimes you get lucky and
so I'm gonna take that same directory
that same run secrets kubernetes i/o
service account that's being mounted
into the pod I'll set a variable called
der to that export der that just to make
this a little bit easier to type a
little more manageable so if I look at
the door got the CA cert namespace token
just like before let's go and run alias
coop controls gonna mean that same way
we did before so servers out on 10960
one that was what we found from that
environment variable and now let's look
at our alias
that's that token being pasted in so
coop control get pods cool we've got a
front ends we've got front end pods
we've got a Redis master we've got we've
got an Apache status that thing we saw
before we're in the front end so let's
try launching a pod could control attack
a plus so could control apply I like it
as coop control attack attack pod and it
says sorry your service count front end
isn't allowed the create resources
wha-wha so and this is where I get to my
slide so we'll do that real quick
I was considering for this one oh damn
it let's just keep the me screen
mirrored so I was considering for this
one doing a spandex quote from the movie
and I decided that wasn't a that wasn't
a sentiment I wanted to voice so I see
that I am I see that I'm going to make
sure that I'm moving on time so at this
point we'll go back to our original move
it back to the other thing we could do
so our two options where do we want to
launch a pot or exactly the back end so
let's exactly a back end and let's try
exacting into another pod so we'll go
like we did the other likely to our
other demo we'll try exacting into a pod
keep wishing we had a better terminal
coop and roll get pods I see that
there's a Redis that there's a Redis
that Redis set up remember I was pushing
Redis keys I might try to investigate
the Redis and see what else now that
I've got direct I've got more direct
access to it but because Redis is very
often well almost always on
authenticated but let's go to the
reddest pod so I'm rooting there
I'm retinas master I'll grab a copy the
meterpreter binary I've been using just
because that's a very convenient way of
putting files into something and
background that and I'm gonna I'm gonna
switch over now that I've got the I've
got the Redis master that pod and
running my interpreter so I'm gonna
switch over and catch that session and
so in that session I'll go and upload
the same coop control that I did before
I'll also upload that attack pod that I
just used before and I'll also attacks
and add something called attack demon
set just in case we need it so
now look another choice so you're in the
back end do you want to try host
mounting pause or do you want to check
out the cloudy Pais cloud api's call
okay
so here we are and I'm going to show you
this in two ways and can I get a rough
time check how much time when you let me
be late Oh less than five okay so this
is where I normally kick on the speed
control so okay so we're in a pod we're
in that Redis master pod and we say hey
I'd like to talk to the metadata API so
every cloud provider gives you one six
nine two five four one six nine two five
four that part's common what the calls
are they make against it they document
wonderfully and you read the
documentation so this is on this is on
GC P so I'm gonna go and say can you
tell me what the project ID is I need
that project ID to do API calls but then
the more interesting one is usually
where you say would you mind in addition
to the project ID which I'm going to set
into a variable would you mind telling
me what service accounts are assigned to
them to the Machine I'm on so the
machine is pods running on and there are
two but default is mapped to that other
one so I'm just gonna use default
because it's easier typing and I'm gonna
go and say okay for that service account
would you do me a favor just give me a
bearer token that I can use to act as
that service account and it's a short
here's your token it expires in like a
half an hour or an hour but I've got a
token so I'll set it variable to that
and now what I'm gonna do is say let's
go and I've set that token to that and I
mean I need to refresh that token so
most of my commands will pull that token
over and over every command so I'm gonna
use that token type out authorization
bearer token where the tokens provided
say I'll take JSON and now I'll say hey
for this project I'd like a list of
buckets and it says oh there's only one
okay well what's in that bucket and so I
basically say give me a list of objects
and the way I do that is it's like /b
for list of buckets then it's the /b
that bucket /o for a list of objects and
then for those objects I can run through
them now on this one I don't find
anything that's all that useful I don't
find I find I don't find what I find in
some cloud environment so I'm going to
show you in another demo somehow and but
I do find a coup B and V so I can pull
in a metadata instance for this cluster
that was set by the Installer and when I
do that what I get out of it is among
other things a couple service count
tokens for the cluster and that ends up
leading which I won't now show you but
that that ends up leading to win and so
just for the end of our for the end of
that that then leads to our crash and
burn so if if Ming will let me have one
more minute I will show you a cooler
version of that we have a tool that were
that we keep soft releasing but never
kind of like putting up on Twitter but
so it's called peratis and peratis will
if I if I actually just
I'm just nervous so it's in here but
somehow I'm
let's do this
so peratis is basically a remote access
trojan for for kubernetes you run this
and it does all kinds of things and I'm
gonna start this from the beginning but
it is under two minutes and then I will
get the heck off the stage and tell you
that you should ask me for stickers so
it's got a bunch of things one of those
I had said okay 13 go get the I am
credentials from GCP the same thing we
just did get the cloud service account
and then come on J type faster highlight
faster so that's for that same one I
just got and now let's take that and
let's pull let's go looking in GCS in
blue and in the button storage buckets
for service count tokens oh look this
installer this one was cops in left left
service count tokens therefore all the
components including a cluster admin
which would be perfectly useful and so
that's the like basically that's
probably roughly what happened at
Capital One recently where it was talked
to the metadata API get your G's get
your get your cloud account use that to
go raiding for information or access so
anyway so now once I've done that
varieties will basically store every
every count it gets and then you
basically say ok I'm in a switch context
and you go and you go through and you
collect all of the service count tokens
then you basically have this big old
store that's your loot and it keeps it
in memory and and you run around and
basically get more access and get more
access we've even got a this isn't this
video will be up on YouTube but we've
even got something that basically takes
over the nodes if it's allowed to it's
allowed to mount the host path volume
it'll go and add a cron job that will
send in that cat shell back to your back
to the IP address of your choice so once
we have this cluster admin we're allowed
to we can go and do everything which
included like hey now show me all the
secrets and all the secrets includes all
of the tokens all the service counts for
every other for every component
and varieties will not just grab it and
will not just list these and get them
but it'll also store them let you use
them so it's a fun little pen test tool
and it's up on github we'd love some
help we'd love some help producing it
so it's an in Guardians tool we do a ton
of kubernetes working on guardians and I
will now get off the stage and take
questions all the way out in the hallway
so if you see me please ask me for
sticker
[Applause]